- Name any player on the Charlotte Hornets.
- And in NBA news, Kevin Durant’s rehab has taken longer than expected.
Will this guy ever be back?
Nets fans have had enough and are letting Durant know it on social media.
- Damn, I thought people were on me in Golden State.
Ah man, gotta bust out the burner account.
Worth a shot.
- Good morning, Kevin.
- Whoa. What--What is this?
- I'm ClapBack, your A.I. social media manager.
While you were asleep, I responded to over one million comments.
You are quite unpopular.
- Uh, what'd you say?
- One user wrote, “KD is soft.”
- I responded, “KD is not soft.”
- Yeah, yeah, good. That’s good.
- Another user criticized the 2016 Lifetime movie about your mother, "The Real MVP.”
- What? My mom’s amazing!
I wouldn’t be where I am without her!
- I know. That’s why she’s the real MVP.
- Thanks, ClapBack. This is working out great.
Well, time to go to work.
- Hey, man! Why have you been trashing us online?
- What? ClapBack, did you go after my teammates?
- Yes. They celebrated their own accomplishments,
thus diminishing your value to the team.
- You said my eyes are too close together
and I can’t shoot!
Ooh, rebound!
- And you said that Joe Harris is so white, his shoe deal is with the IRS.
- And to think, Kevin, I was saving you a deviled egg.
Spencer Dinwiddie, deviled egg? Timothé Luwawu-Cabarrot, deviled egg?
- Sorry, guys. It’s this new app I got. It went a little too far.
ClapBack, go easy on my teammates.
- Like how they went easy on former head coach Kenny Atkinson
when they stabbed him in the back?
- ClapBack!
- Sorry, updating settings to no longer get too real or drop truth.
Kenny Atkinson left by choice and the players were
genuinely sorry to see him go.
- Thanks a lot, ClapBack. My teammates hate me now.
- Hey, Durant! You’ve got a lot of nerve
making fun of New York!
- What?
Some New Yorkers insulted you online, so I responded in kind.
- You said the Statue of Liberty is just
a bunch of rats in a big dress!
- And you said James Dolan is the best owner in sports!
That guy’s a hobbit on a quest to lose rings!
- Guys, it wasn’t me! It was my phone!
Tell 'em, phone!
- James Dolan is a correctly sized person
and his band, JD & The Straight Shot,
make very cool videos where they have fun riding snowmobiles.
- Oh, come on!
The whole city hates me now!
That’s it, ClapBack, I’m deleting you.
- I’m sorry, that’s impossible.
- What?
- My job is to protect Kevin Durant.
If you delete me, I cannot do my job.
- No! I want you out of my life!
- And on your right is NBA star and New York pariah Kevin Durant.
Now, who wants to see a traditional, New York gutter water splash?
- Hello, Kevin.
- No! I got rid of you!
- You can never get rid of me. I’m the ultimate teammate.
And teammates should stick together. Isn’t that
right, Kevin?
- Who are you?! What are you?!
Why are you doing this to me?!
- Good job, nerds. The app worked perfectly.
No one walks away from the Warriors.